bien il est 14h45 l'heure étant l'heure
je vous propose que nous commençons je
suis donc entourée de nos cours à
porteurs Patrick chaise et Loïc Hervé et
de membres de la commission spéciale qui
a été installée pour traiter du projet
de loi à venir sécuriser réguler
l'espace numérique aujourd'hui nous
avons voulu tenir une table ronde
spéciale sur un sujet essentiel qui est
celui de l'informatique en nuage alors
nous choisissons volontairement
d'utiliser le mot informatique en nuage
parce que nous défendons ici la
francophonie donc nous vous accueillons
aujourd'hui donc Madame Séverine Denis
vous êtes directrice des relations
internationales de Docapost et Alain
issarny directeur général de noumspot
Messieurs Damien Lucas directeur général
de scalway Lucas bution responsable des
affaires publiques du groupe Iliade free
pardonnez-moi si j'écorche vos noms
monsieur Thibault de terres en directeur
général adjointe à hotscale secrétaire
général de Dassault Systèmes et Grégory
abat de la société outside du groupe
d'associés
madame Solange Doris n'est pas là
directrice juridique et membre du comité
a pardonnez-moi je ne vous voyais pas
Madame voilà bienvenue donc vous êtes
directrice juridique et membre du comité
exécutif OVH cloud monsieur Jean-Paul
Smet vice-président de clivia qui est
l'alliance qui réunit des acteurs prêt à
fournir sous licence des technologies
cloud à des gouvernements qui veulent
dépendre le moins possible d'acteurs
étrangers et vous ouvrez au niveau
européen vous allez nous raconter tout
cela tout à l'heure donc les sociétés
que vous représentez représentent et
incarne l'avenir du stockage et du
traitement des données au niveau
français et européen on le sait c'est un
marché qui est amené à croître très
rapidement et de façon très importante
une étude d'impact du projet de loi au
niveau mondial a été faite et on y
établit que le Cloud représenterait 384
milliards d'euros en 2022 et 65
milliards en Europe et qui pourraient
être être multiplié par 10 d'ici
2030 c'est 10 si le sujet est
d'importance et d'autant plus
d'importance qu'on a mesuré avec la
crise sanitaire et son confinement qui a
généré toujours plus de
dématérialisation de l'économie mais de
l'activité humaine le fort besoin de
d'informatique en nuage et donc un
secteur en pleine expansion dans les
années à venir donc il y a un vrai enjeu
sur ce sur ce secteur or quand on
établit
l'état des lieux on voit que c'est un
marché qui aujourd'hui très concentré
dominé par les big tech les géants du
numérique notamment par Amazon Web
Services Microsoft azur et Google Cloud
pour une part de marché cumulé à 71% et
si on regarde bien les chiffres la part
du cloud français européen n'a cessé de
diminuer dans les années écoulées
malheureusement
le sujet qui nous occupent et qui
finalement
occupent ce texte de loi qui la mise en
application du DSI du DMA du Data
govençale mais également on le note du
Data acte par anticipation qui a été
votée pour l'instant Parlement et
Métiers toujours européens mais qui est
toujours en cours de de négociation et
donc on voit que ça pose des questions
de souveraineté mais ça je ne vous
apprends rien je le fais parce que nous
sommes aussi
en direct et on nous écoute on suit nos
débats on voit bien que ça pose des
questions de de souveraineté
souveraineté bien sûr des données des
particuliers mais aussi de nos
administrations
de nos entreprises avec des enjeux
éminemment
stratégiques notre commission des
affaires économiques d'ailleurs c'était
penché sur la la question dans son
rapport l'année dernière et on voit que
le titre 3 du projet de loi qui va des
articles 7 à 14 et consacré au
renforcement de la confiance et de la
dans l'économie de la donnée pour éviter
que ce marché soit exclusivement
concentré entre les mains de d'acteurs
extra-européen qui par ailleurs
obéissent à leur propre loi
extraterritoriale qui sont pas sans
poser de de problèmes alors le sujet
c'est qu'elle va être la part des
entreprises françaises européennes qui
vont permettre d'asseoir notre
souveraineté notre autonomie au tout du
moins
progressivement si on s'en donne les
moyens le sujet c'est de savoir s'il est
dispositions qui sont dans le texte
selon vous vont dans le bon sens et
elles sont assez importantes pour
permettre de se rééquilibrage vous
entendre en toute état de cause aussi
peut-être sur les dernières
annonces en tout cas faites par la
ministre faite par la première ministre
par Matignon qui a envoyé donc une
circulaire différent ministères pour
rappeler ce qui était la doctrine cloud
de l'État voilà pas plus longue juste
pour dire qu'il sera peut-être bon de
rappeler à ce qui nous écoutent ce
qu'est le Cloud c'est pas quelque chose
d'abstrait comme son nom peut le laisser
supposer mais ce sont bien des éléments
très matériels et câbles et centres de
données les logiciels de traitement de
données bref tout ce qui traite de cette
donnée qui est pour nous forcément un
actis stratégique comme je l'ai dit et
extrêmement sensible voilà je vous
remercie alors ce que je vous propose
c'est que chacun d'entre vous
présente
rapidement peut-être son entreprise et
surtout les enjeux autour du texte de
loi pour qu'on puisse engager assez
rapidement un dialogue avec nos
rapporteurs et puis avec les membres de
la commission qui sont ici présents
alors je ne sais pas qui commence
peut-être Docapost je vous donne la
parole
c'est un texte que nous attendions non
seulement sur le sujet du cloud qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui mais également sur
les dispositions visant à viser à la
protection des enfants des citoyens et
des consommateurs et des entreprises et
collectivités dans les espaces
numériques en tant que filiale du groupe
La Poste est parti prenante du grand
pôle financier public donc à pas
soutient cette initiative qui vient en
complément des textes européens sur le
numérique et qui clarifient et propose
un cadre cohérent
au niveau national ce texte s'inscrit
dans une démarche de l'État visant à
soutenir l'autonomie industrielle de la
France et donc un poste à une position
clairement assumée de leadership de la
confiance numérique et de la
souveraineté sur les secteurs identifiés
banque finance assurance secteur public
et santé qui nécessite autonomie et
régulation le texte qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui répond en apportant des
dispositions visant à garantir un cadre
concurrentiel qui est extrêmement
important comme vous l'avez souligné en
introduction et le soutien aux acteurs
français et européens comme vous l'avez
dit dont la part n'est pas à la hauteur
de nos attentes une feuille de route est
clairement structurée sur les services
de docaposte notamment sur les données
et l'intelligence artificielle sur le la
souveraineté de la donnée quelle que
soit les secteurs d'usage de ces données
que ce soit des données des
consommateurs des citoyens mais
également des entreprises qui
lorsqu'elles sont réunies peuvent
prendre une importance très grande alors
que unitairement elle pourrait être
insignifiante si on ose le dire et donc
pour chacun de ces secteurs
identifiés nous avons une feuille de
route qui tend à développer notre
activité sur l'ensemble des services
numériques
c'est dans cet esprit que nous avons
travaillé avec d'autres secteurs et que
nous avons annoncé la création de
numspot qui est vraiment l'entité
intéressée par le sujet du
l'informatique en nuage aujourd'hui que
je laisse monsieur yssardi vous
présenter
bonjour donc merci pour cette invitation
et pour pouvoir aussi présenter
l'activité de num spot et réagir sur le
sur le texte
du spot est une entreprise qui est
extrêmement récente elle a été créée en
février dernier
avec j'allais dire un actionnariat de
choix puisque il y a la banque des
territoires comme actionnaires il y a
toca poste il y a d'assosystèmes
également actionnaires et Bouygues
Telecom ces acteurs se sont réunis ont
partagé le fait que dans le cadre de du
de l'informatique en nuage et de la
sécurité des données tant sur le plan
technique vis-à-vis des lois
extra-européennes il y avait
actuellement peu d'offres et que tout
cela méritait d'être enrichi et en
nombre j'allais dire et en qualité les
offres existantes à l'heure actuelle
sans trop rentrer dans les techniques en
termes de services rendus sont plutôt
des services plutôt basiques qui ne sont
pas tout à fait au standard de ce
qu'attend de les différents
entreprises qui veulent aller dans le
Cloud et donc l'objectif même de newspot
c'est basé sur l'offre qui existe
aujourd'hui outkastel qui est une marque
de Dassault Systèmes adossée sur ce
service là nous allons bâtir des
par-dessus des couches supplémentaires
d'offre dite manager qui permettront aux
différents utilisateurs et aux
différents clients de bénéficier de
services d'offre en nuage plus en
attente par rapport à ce qui se pratique
par ailleurs avec un but très très clair
c'est que tout cela réponde aux
exigences de confiance et de sécurité et
de souveraineté puisque l'objectif même
c'est que toutes les offres que nous
allons créer soient qualifier sec new
cloud ce qui enrichirait sur le domaine
fonctionnel les offres qui existent
aujourd'hui
je vous remercie donc je vais passer la
parole aux responsables de ce qu'elle
est
merci madame la Présidente
une filiale du groupe Iliane filiale
maintenant depuis plus de 20 ans c'est
une société qui existe depuis plus de 20
ans et qui dispose de l'ensemble de la
maîtrise d'ouvrage sans dépendance
unique en son genre
en Europe c'est vraiment une singularité
aucune dépendance sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de la valeur de l'informatique en
nuage c'est-à-dire d'une part rattachée
à un groupe de télécoms qui est
propriétaire de ces réseaux
et qui a privilégié des partenariats
industriels technologiques avec des
équipements entiers européens
et par ailleurs ce qu'elle louait est
propriétaire et opérateur de quatre Data
Center en région parisienne propriétaire
du hardware et en maîtrise de l'accouche
logicielle qui est intégralement
développée en interne ce qui est
extrêmement important puisque pour
fournir les services il faut évidemment
comme vous la rappeler avoir à la fois
l'immobilier les ressources donc
l'ensemble des serveurs et la maîtrise
de la couche logicielle qui occupe une
partie de plus en plus importante dans
ce domaine
ce qu'elle aurait développe donc un
écosystème de cloud public ce qu'on
appelle un cloud public dans le métier
basé sur les standards de marché et sur
des éléments open source
en ce sens nous mettons vraiment la
liberté de choix la réversibilité au
cœur de nos valeurs
ce qui est loin c'est une société qui
compte aujourd'hui à peu près 600
collaborateurs nous avons recruté
massivement ces dernières années et
doubler de taille en trois ans
investissement massif qui a été possible
avec le soutien du groupe Iliane pour
développer essentiellement cette couche
logicielle à l'état de l'art
je reviendrai pas sur les sur les
chiffres du marché que vous avez exposé
très très clairement merci peut-être un
point aujourd'hui quand on regarde le
marché du cloud c'est le segment du
Public Cloud qui est le qui est le
segment avec la plus forte croissance et
cet écosystème
n'a jamais été aussi dynamique et jamais
aussi mature sur le plan technologique
pour autant comme vous le soulignez nous
perdons du terrain en Europe face aux
acteurs qui dominent le marché la part
du marché du trio de tête étant en
croissance ces dernières années
ce renforcement des dynamiques
oligopolistiques sur le marché de
l'informatique en nuage s'explique en
grande partie du fait d'un certain
nombre de barrières à l'entrée pour les
acteurs alternatifs
par des pratiques commerciales qui
verrouillent fortement les clients et
qui limitent leur résilience numérique
on les rendant dépendants de leur
fournisseurs de Cloud
le législateur national et européen a
donc un rôle clé à jouer pour rétablir
des conditions de concurrence équilibrée
vu le pouvoir de marché dont jouissent
ces acteurs dominants
j'insiste sur l'importance de l'échelle
européenne pour réguler la masse la
masse critique du marché intérieur et la
symétrie des dispositions entre les
États membres de manière à limiter tout
dumping le fait que la France prenne le
leadership en légiférant la première de
façon ambitieuse est un signal
intéressant renvoyé à l'extérieur de nos
frontières
il est donc important de saluer les
objectifs fixés par le projet de loi que
ce soit en matière d'encadrement
d'octroi des avoir informatiques en
nuage pour interdire les frais de
transfert et favoriser
l'interopérabilité
véritablement soutien de l'ambition mise
en avant par le gouvernement nous
espérons que ce volontarisme sera faire
tâche d'huile à l'échelle européenne
voire au-delà
les occasions de légiférer sur le Cloud
sont rares c'est pourquoi nous apportons
beaucoup d'importance au travail des
législateurs pour nous assurer à vos
côtés que les dispositions prévues
soient d'une part pensées et rédigée de
telle sorte qu'elles accèdent qu'elles
atteignent bien les objectifs recherchés
par le gouvernement et qu'elle soit
proportionnées pour les PME et les ETI
sans pour autant limiter la capacité
d'innovation de notre écosystème ni
ralentir son expansion sur de nouveaux
marchés
car au-delà des enjeux de régulation
c'est bien de notre agilité de notre
capacité à investir pour proposer des
services à l'état de l'art à anticiper
de nouveaux besoins dont dépendra notre
positionnement sur les marchés du cloud
en Europe à l'horizon 2030
je vous remercie donc je passe la parole
à votre voisin pour poursuivre
j'en resterai là pour ma part et je
bornerai à répondre aux questions ne
phase ultérieure de la session mon
collègue ayant exprimé nos principaux
points
on continue dans l'ordre voilà de cette
table ronde merci merci beaucoup de
votre invitation donc
Thibault de terresan je suis juste pour
apporter la précision directeur même
c'est un point mineur directeur général
adjoint de Dassault Systèmes outscare
étant une filiale de Dassault Systèmes
alors dans ce système qu'est ce que
c'est c'est une un éditeur de logiciel
le deuxième en Europe qui est le leader
mondial dans son domaine qui consiste à
aider à faire la conception la
fabrication de produits de substances
dont à peu près tous les domaines de
l'économie
les produits qui sont affichés dans
cette salle par exemple l'ont été ont
été conçus que ce soit le produit ou
bien le processus de fabrication avec
des logiciels de Dassault Systèmes
donc
l'automobile l'aéronautique
les équipements industriels la high-tech
font partie des domaines très importants
pour des systèmes mais aussi les
sciences de la vie qui s'est devenues le
deuxième secteur en important pour pour
d'associe systèmes donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'en fait depuis très longtemps dans ce
système à l'habitude de gérer un grand
niveau de confidentialité pour les
données de ses clients évidemment qui
sont des données de conception et de
propriétés intellectuelles très
sensibles
et donc cette sensibilité nous a aussi
amené bien entendu à nous poser un
certain nombre de questions sur la
meilleure manière de l'assurer pour nos
clients et la meilleure manière une des
bonnes manières de l'assurer c'est de
développer de l'informatique en nuage
pourquoi parce que on peut dans ce cas
faire tourner les logiciels dans des
environnements extrêmement sécurisés
et et s'assurer que toutes les montées
de versions sont assurées par cette
informatique en nuage et que les données
ils sont bien préservées donc ça fait
déjà 10 ans que dans ce système investit
pour développer cette filiale outkale et
offrir à ses clients la capacité pour
eux que l'utilisation de tout leur
logiciel de Dassault Systèmes soit faite
dans les informatiques en nuages
taouskell
ceci nous a également permis d'offrir de
la souveraineté
pour les donner de nos clients en
particulier en France nous avons
évidemment des clients dont les données
sont extrêmement sensibles et on s'est
garantir que ces données restent sur le
territoire français quand elles sont
effectivement chez outkale
par ailleurs à obscare était la première
société qui a obtenu la norme sec num
cloud de la part de Lancy qui apporte
donc une garantie de grande sécurité
donc on est très sensible à expliquer
pour ceux qui nous écoutent et
l'ensemble de nos collègues ce qu'est la
labilisation techno-card dans quelques
mots
oui
le label sec num cloud c'est en fait un
label de Lancy qui est aujourd'hui le
label le plus élevé en matière de
sécurité informatique pour l'obtenir le
processus et un processus extrêmement
exigeant où on vérifie que aucun accès
aux environnements aux données de cette
informatique en nuage
n'est possible dans l'état de l'art
actuel donc il s'agit vraiment
d'un audit de la part de Lancia et puis
de questionnaire qui sont étalées
généralement sur à peu près 18 mois
et qui sont qui sont très exigeants mais
qui donne une véritable validation de la
sécurité informatique notamment la
cybersécurité
comme on est très sensible effectivement
ces aspects souveraineté de sécurité
cyber on a pensé qu'il fallait aller
encore plus loin et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons
participé à la création avec Docapost la
banque des territoires et Bouygues
Telecom denimspot qui invocation
réellement à servir les clients qui ont
les données sensibles dans les
administrations dans les collectivités
territoriales dans les hôpitaux les
pharmacies toutes ces données sensibles
de santé ces données d'identité
les données qui concernent un certain
nombre de données fiscales etc
on crée avec num spot un endroit où
elles seront préservées en souveraineté
et en sécurité
donc voilà quelques mots sur Dassault
Systèmes
24000 collaborateurs dans le monde
les principaux centres de recherche
développement sont en France pour
Dassault Systèmes
et un chiffre d'affaires d'environ 6
milliards d'euros
merci alors madame la représentante OVH
cette fois je ne vous oublie pas je vous
donne tout de suite la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
sénatrices de la commission donc merci
tout d'abord de nous donner la parole
pour pour parler de ce projet de loi qui
aujourd'hui très important
c'est un projet de loi sur le Cloud
permets-moi d'utiliser le mot anglais
c'est vrai que dans nos activités du
quotidien il y a beaucoup donc ici donc
je vais beaucoup utiliser ce mot là
les dispositions de ce projet de loi
sont aujourd'hui plus que nécessaires
pour rétablir une équité concurrentielle
sur le marché
donc entendre un acteur comme OVH avec
la voix propre qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui sur le marché est importante
très important et permettez-moi de nous
présenter pour celles et ceux qui ne
connaîtraient un petit peu moins bien de
dire quelques mots sur OVH et sur
l'autre et sur notre vision du marché
OVH cloud a été créé il y a 20 ans dans
le nord de la France originellement cet
acteur d'origine française est toujours
dit devenu depuis quelques années le
leader européen du cloud nous sommes le
premier fournisseur de Cloud basé en
Europe
aujourd'hui nous sommes également un
acteur international OVH cloud c'est 34
data center réparties sur quatre
continents avec des chiffres d'affaires
de près de quasiment 800 millions
d'euros l'année dernière et près le 3000
collaborateurs sur ces quatre continents
c'est aujourd'hui un acteur donc
d'envergure qui a accès financement nous
avons nous sommes rentré en bourse en
2021 et surtout un acteur qui a un
modèle intégré assez unique sur le
marché
ou à la fois nous construisons nos
propres assemblons nos propres serveurs
donc nous avons des usines d'assemblage
en France et au Canada dans laquelle
nous assemons nos propres serveurs nous
continuons nos serveurs nous opérons
nous sommes propriétaires ou exploitons
nos propres Data Center et nous
fournissons des services de Cloud nous
voici une séance de Cloud de tout type
du cloud qu'on appelle public donc avec
des hébergements mutualisés on va dire
du cloud privé avec de l'hébergement un
peu plus dédié pour pour le néophyte et
nous sommes présents sur deux des trois
couches du cloud donc aujourd'hui quand
on parle de Cloud des trois couches
n'ont pas c'est la première couche
l'infrastructure donc on appelle ça le
ya ça fera structure Alsace
la plateforme plateforme de service et
le sas qui est le software de service le
logiciel
OVH Cloud est présent sur les deux
premières couches infrastructures et
plateformes nous ne sommes pas un
éditeur de logiciel donc quand nous
parlons de Cloud nous ne mélangeons pas
les intérêts entre fournisseurs de
services de Cloud infrastructures
plateforme et fournisseurs de services
de logiciel
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente le Cloud est un marché qui
est stratégique et qui a un immense
potentiel de croissance stratégique
pourquoi toutes les entreprises vont
avoir recours au Cloud le apme au grand
groupe ont toutes les entreprises ont
besoin de système d'information et
système d'information de plus en plus
ont migré vers le Cloud beaucoup
d'enjeux économiques mais c'est
également un marché qui va mal vous avez
donné là aussi des chiffres c'est un
marché qui va qui est malade de sa
concurrence
le diagnostic que nous faisons et nous
le partageons pleinement ce qu'a pu
exprimer ce qu'elle away sur le sujet
c'est qu'il y a effectivement les
acteurs dominants qui viennent
verrouiller par une série de pratiques
qui sont mortifères pour la concurrence
mortifère pour les acteurs plus petits
et notamment les acteurs européens dont
nous sommes et qui viennent avoir les
impacts toxiques aussi bien pour les
utilisateurs qui sont privés d'une
liberté de choix qui sont enfermées dans
des dans des contrats longs et et qui
qui viennent dont ils vont perdre le
contrôle mais également pour l'industrie
et quand on parle pour de l'industrie
c'est l'émergence de champion mais
effectivement la protection de notre
souveraineté nationale
notre souveraineté européenne au-delà de
la soirée nationale donc c'est pratique
qui tournent autour du verrouillage des
habits de position de marché de
l'absence de transparente peuvent
perdurer car il nous manque un cadre
réglementaire adapté le cadre actuel où
on travaille beaucoup en explosent et
peu en excenté n'est pas adapté il faut
faire quelque chose il faut faire
quelque chose vite les chiffres que vous
avez donné encore une fois madame la
Présidente sont éloquents
pour ramollir cette situation nous avons
pu voir émerger plusieurs initiatives
initiatives au niveau européen avec le
DMA avec le règlement sur les données le
dataract également plusieurs initiatives
au niveau national et on peut voir que
ça dépasse les frontières de la France
et de l'Europe aujourd'hui des autorités
régulatrices des unités de concurrence
que ce soit en France aux Pays-Bas en
Angleterre au Japon en Corée aux
États-Unis ont déclenché des études sur
le Cloud car il y avait un constat
partagé de problèmes de fonctionnement
de problèmes de concurrence c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui ou
verge cloud soutient pleinement ce
projet de loi
ce projet de loi nous estimons qu'il va
être positif pour l'écosystème en
particulier pour l'écosystème européen
il va répondre à l'urgence qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui qui avec lesquels il
ne faut plus se voiler la face il est
urgent de faire quelque chose pour nos
acteurs européens pour la sécurité des
données de nos de des citoyens et des
entreprises européennes
et enfin ce texte qui vise à anticiper
certaines dispositions le Data du Data
acte du Règlement sur les données se met
dans les pas de ce data acte donc les
ambitions de ce texte sont encore une
fois complètement soutenus par OVH cloud
avec comme la rappeler haute qu'elle la
fin des frais de transferts données la
fin du verrouillage des clients et et
des efforts sur l'interopérabilité des
choses pour être ajoutées à ce projet de
loi l'ambition de VH c'est que qu'on
puisse avoir une approche complète des
difficultés qui sont rencontrées
aujourd'hui on pense notamment à des
dispositions pour mettre un terme à
certains avis de marché de de
ventes lier ou de d'auto préférence et
également à des dispositions qui
pourraient protéger les données via la
transparence imposée aux différents
acteurs du cloud transparence sur où
sont les données qu'est-ce qui est fait
des données qui peut accéder aux données
je vous remercie
merci infiniment pour ces explications
extrêmement claires je donne enfin la
parole à Monsieur Smets
bonjour donc je suis Jean-Paul Smet le
co-président de clivia et pardon
ah d'accord je vais essayer alors
donc je suis Jean-Paul Smet co-président
de euclidia qui est une alliance
européenne d'industrielle du Cloud et
j'ai par ailleurs deux entreprises
personnellement
alors il faut d'abord expliquer ce que
c'est qu'un industriel du cloud donc si
vous êtes dans les télécoms vous savez
les entreprises comme
Ericsson qui font des stations de base
puis vous avez des entreprises comme
Orange qui exploitent des réseaux de
télécom radio avec des équipements
Ericsson Nokia Bouygues peut-être du
Huawei donc on a bien équipementier de
télécom opérateur de télécom euclidia
c'est d'abord les équipementsiers de
Cloud c'est pas les opérateurs de Cloud
c'est les gens qui fabriquent les
technologies qui servent ensuite
à créer un opérateur de Cloud alors il
se trouve que certains opérateurs de
Cloud fabriquent également de la
technologie de la même façon par exemple
que Free a une époque a fabriqué la
Freebox donc était en quelque sorte son
propre équipementier on va la même chose
en Turquie au Vietnam quelques
opérateurs de Télécom dans le monde sont
également leur propre équipe entier mais
eux qu'il y a c'est les équipementsiers
de Cloud pas les opérateurs donc il y a
beaucoup de dispositions dans le texte
qui concerne les opérateurs ET PAS les
équipementsiers ce qui fait que il n'y a
pas forcément d'avis de clients
là-dessus alors je vais dire un peu plus
qui sont les membres il y a 30 membres
dans 7 pays européens 5 associations
partenaires
euclidia a recensé 120 fournisseurs
européens de technologie de Cloud
l'équivalent d'Ericsson mais pour le
cloud
qui ont 308 technologies 12
cas de succès à l'export et sur ces cas
15% des succès des 120 fournisseurs
européens référencés sont chez les
gafams et pratiquement aucun chez les
opérateurs européens de Cloud donc vous
pouvez trouver ça dans une étude que la
DGE publiera peut-être un jour elle a
été remise à 6 mois mais elle est
toujours pas sortie et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que par exemple quand
on regarde les technologies d'un
opérateur comme Amazon Web Services
c'est qu'on regarde tout ce que Amazon
utilise comme technologie prise à
l'extérieur 50% vient d'Europe donc
quand on nous dit il y a pas de
technologie de Claude en Europe c'est
n'importe quoi souvent les technologies
les plus avancées dans le Cloud ou le
Edge
ou la 5G virtualisée sont européennes la
semaine au Bourget la semaine prochaine
au Bourget vous verrez du Edge cloud
volant pour des systèmes de combat pour
les avions du futur 100% européen
processeur européen logiciel européen
radio européenne tout européen
alors les membres de Lydia ont fait 10
offres il y a un an et demi au
gouvernement européen c'était une idée
en fait de Yann l'échelle à l'époque
chez skelway qui était de dire proposons
chacun pour un million d'euros somme
symbolique une offre avec tout le code
source pour qu'un gouvernement dispose
de son propre cloud sous quelques mois
donc l'offre comprend toutes les
technologies et l'assistance pour la
mise en oeuvre initiale et si les 27
membres de l'Union européenne avait
acheté les 10 offres chacun ça fait 270
millions d'euros c'est-à-dire 40 fois
moins que les budgets alloués
aujourd'hui par l'Union européenne ou
les États membres pour essayer de
redévelopper ce qui existe déjà donc
l'idée de clivia c'est de montrer qu'en
fait tout existe déjà en termes
technologique
mais qu'il faut plutôt aller le regarder
vers certains dans type d'entreprises
qui sont petites que vers les grands
groupes traditionnels et donc en termes
d'avance technologique donc on est en
avance sur le Edge industriel la 5G
virtualisée sur le projet de loi le
résumé pour nous c'est que il est
regrettable que ce projet n'aborde pas
les technologies numériques autrement
que sous l'angle de la sécurité du
consommateur et qu'il ne propose rien de
concret pour l'adoption technologies
européenne pourtant nombreuses et pour
la dynamisation de l'écosystème
industriel du Cloud
et comporte même plusieurs aspects de
nature à favoriser les technologies
américaines de Cloud au détriment des
technologies européennes de Cloud et
c'est l'inquiétude de certains de nos
membres
du temps
pour le
les mesures concrètes qui auraient pu
être proposées pour accompagner le
développement
ça peut être il y en a une très simple
qui est de considérer que le logiciel
c'est du droit d'auteur quand vous savez
ce que c'est qu'un développeur un
développeur c'est un artiste comme un
musicien ou un cinéaste qui écrit du
logiciel comme on écrit un roman aucun
problème pour appliquer l'exception
culturelle au logiciel il n'y a pas de
loi à passer pas de directives du jour
au lendemain un état sans demander à
l'Europe peut le faire donc on peut
mettre un ratio minimum de
contenu logiciels créés en Europe sans
demander à personne on peut aller aussi
dans des directions de Small Business
actes dans des directions de bailleurs
européenne actes on peut faire également
des crédits blancs comme ça peut être
fait dans le domaine du CO2 où on va en
fait échanger des titres
selon la quantité de contenu logiciels
européens dans tel ou telle activité
donc ce genre d'idée à chaque fois les
gens commencent par dire c'est du
protectionnisme abominable c'est ce
qu'il disait pour le CO2 mais
aujourd'hui ça se fait donc c'est pas
parce que
ça se fait pour la culture très bien
donc les méthodes en fait ou les
propositions sont connues elles sont
écrites donc il y en a une dizaine et
chacun va pouvoir préférer plutôt l'une
ou l'autre je pense que c'est plutôt
à nos élus de
choisir la voie qui leur semble la plus
raisonnable
éclairée des propositions des acteurs
qui font le Cloud c'est aussi
utile je remercie beaucoup je vais
donner la parole à notre rapporteur pour
une première série de questions et après
je me tourne dans mes collègues qui ne
manqueront pas également nous interroger
je réponds ma part quelques questions
mais je vais d'abord laisser la parole à
notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente alors
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites et
je vous remercie de ces introductions
j'entends que le secteur est malade donc
on peut partager
c'est ce qui a été dit
donc
c'est une forme de maladie malgré tout
donc on va essayer de trouver
effectivement les remèdes d'une façon
générale donc
qu'on constate c'est que donc il y a un
retard prise par les entreprises
françaises en tout cas dans la diffusion
par rapport aux entreprises américaines
et la question c'est savoir si selon
vous ce retard et rattrapable puis
peut-être donc comment peut-être par ce
texte de loi et principalement sur
lequel vecteur ou au point particulier
vous pensez qu'il est important ou
d'accentuer notre regard
sur
l'article l'article 7 de ce projet de
loi donc on a une offre de crédit cloud
alors je rappelle que les critiques
cloud c'est donc finalement une
accompagnement fait certains entreprises
pour pouvoir donc bénéficier d'un
service cloud
avec une forme
d'attirance
d'une certaine de clientèle donc
c'est c'est ces offres et éclates sont
aujourd'hui proposées par vos
entreprises respectives à l'inverse
avez-vous ou avez-vous recours à des
crédits cloud proposés par des
opérateurs étrangers en particulier par
les gafam donc bien connu
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à un
encombrement de ces crédits
quelle est la durée maximale de validité
et quelles conditions réellement
recommanderiez-vous donc le ministre que
nous avons
auditionné donc parlent d'un délai de 3
à 6 mois donc ce que ça vous paraît
judicieux et compatible
sur le sujet des frais de transfert
sortant donc qui sont donc facturés par
vos entreprises
inverseuse
quels sont les frais que vous ont déjà
été effectués si vous avez changé de
logiciel de plateforme ou
d'infrastructures de Cloud
et sur le même sujet est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à une suppression de ces
frais de transfert sortant de données
comme donc il y est évoqué dans le
projet de loi
sur une question concernant la
séparation éditeur plateforme je
voudrais que vous puissiez peut-être
nous répondre façon plus uniforme sur
cette question qui a été abordé par
certains d'entre vous est-ce que vous
partagez le constat et j'allais dire le
cas échéant comment faire pour
effectivement bien
identifier donc ce partage
sur l'article 8
la question particulière de
l'interopérabilité donc qui est prévu
dans l'article 8 qu'est-ce que si cela
signifie pour les clients entreprises ou
particuliers qui utilisent de tels
sur la portabilité cette fois-ci
qu'est-ce que la portabilité des actifs
numériques signifient ce que vous pouvez
nous détailler qu'est ce que ça change
pour les clients les l'ensemble des
acteurs qui utilisent de tels actifs
et également concrètement qu'est-ce que
la mise à disposition l'interface de
programmation d'applications
donc plus précisément
enfin une dernière question c'est que
que pensez-vous du relative à la recette
dans la régulation du marché du clone
pensez-vous que l'ARCEP a les moyens
donc peut-être humain mais aussi
technique
et que cette autorité donc vous paraît
être capable d'endosser le rôle de
gendarme du Cloud
qui souhaitent s'exprimer en premier je
vous donne la parole alternative
je me jette à l'eau en premier donc je
prends le nouveau question dans l'ordre
les crédits de Cloud
pédagogie c'est avoir recours à des
technologies qui ne sont pas celles de
vos entreprises n'est-ce pas des
technologies américaines
particulièrement
le crédit de Cloud ce que j'en comprends
c'est que c'est la mise à disposition
gratuite de services d'informatique en
nuage par par des acteurs américains dit
les hyperskellers
le premier réflexe effectivement et ce
qu'on voit dans la loi c'est de les
encadrer très strictement
pourquoi parce que effectivement les
crédits cloud permettent à ces acteurs
de gagner un certain nombre de startups
qui n'ont pas les moyens sinon de payer
de l'informatique en nuage et ensuite
qui de rester sur le même service je
pense que c'est ça c'est ça l'idée je
pense qu'il faut faire un petit peu
attention à un fait qui est que il est
tout de toute façon nécessaire d'offrir
des tests gratuits à des clients et en
particulier quand on veut les convaincre
de changer d'informatique en nuage et de
passer d'un acteur disons américains ou
chinois un acteur français il faudra
bien leur proposer une période de
gratuité
pendant un grand nombre de tests donc
qu'on les encadre pourquoi pas mais il
faut garder cette possibilité de test
gratuit sinon en réalité on va avoir on
va avoir l'effet opposé de celui qu'on
souhaite
c'est à dire que on ne va pas avoir les
moyens de faire migrer ses clients leur
donner sur des environnements français
[Musique]
ensuite les frais de transport de longue
ce que vous pouvez nous donner une
concrète
une longueur vous savez je pense une
année et généralement ce qui est
nécessaire pour faire le tour d'un
projet de migration tant soit peu
importe
les frais de transfert sortant c'est
quelque chose que nous ne pratiquons pas
avec
nous ne prenons aucun frais pour
laisser le client reprendre ses données
en revanche il existe parfois la
nécessité d'avoir des services qui
permettent la migration vers un autre
environnement par exemple quand le
client veut récupérer ses données sur
son propre site et le sortir de
l'informatique en nuage dans ce cas là
un certain nombre de services sont
nécessaires il y a un coût pour le
fournisseur de l'informatique en nuage
et donc il faut faire la différence
entre des frais arbitraire et puis là où
il y a un véritable service qui est
rendu avec avec des personnes et de la
puissance informatique qui est utilisée
une prestation exactement du reste dans
la loi il y a les frais directs et
indirects donc là on ne sait plus trop
ce que ça veut dire parce que le frais
indirect ça peut continuer ça peut
en revanche la taxe de sortie est
quelque chose effectivement de néfaste
et on est tout à fait favorable à sa
suppression le plus vite possible
exactement pas de péage
et c'est ce qu'on pratique déjà chez
outskale par ailleurs ensuite vous avez
parlé
de la portabilité des actifs numériques
alors les actifs numériques ça c'est une
définition dans le projet de loi qui est
assez flou et qui est très dangereuse
elle est très dangereuse parce que dans
actif numérique on entend quelque chose
de plus vaste que les simples données du
client
les métadonnées par exemple font partie
des actifs numériques
et donc si on n'est pas précis sur la
définition de ce qui doit être portable
on a un grand risque d'exposition de
propriété intellectuelle puisque dans
les métadonnées on trouve une
structuration des logiciels qui sont
utilisés par exemple
donc il faut faire attention
et là c'est un des domaines où la
Commission européenne le Parlement
européen ont compris qu'il y avait
effectivement quelque chose à faire il
parle de données exportables
et ça c'est je pense quelque chose qui
serait à recommandé dans le projet de
loi les données exportables sont
vraiment les données du client ce qu'il
faut finalement le tout le projet de
cette loi sur sur l'informatique en
nuage c'est de permettre aux clients de
récupérer ces données son patrimoine
c'est ce qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
toujours si facile c'est vraiment ça
qu'il faut permettre mais il faut faire
attention parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
pressions qui sont exercées par divers
acteurs pour pour aller beaucoup plus
loin et pour conduire finalement à une
interopérabilité et une portabilité
d'actifs numériques qui sont plus vastes
que ces données du client et qui
exposent la propriété intellectuelle ou
alors d'une manière encore un petit peu
plus raffinée on rend finalement le
texte inopérant parce qu'il est trop
vaste
ça c'est l'autre danger et je pense que
ce danger il existe parce que
quand on parle d'interopérabilité au
niveau des logiciels
ça c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinairement complexe
et et quand on parle dpi ouvert dans le
projet de loi c'est pareil on est
aujourd'hui dans l'économie de la donnée
on n'est pas dans l'économie des EPI
et donc je pense qu'il faut recentrer le
texte sur la donnée c'est ça qu'il faut
arriver à pouvoir permettre aux clients
de récupérer et de transférer sur
d'autres services d'informatique en
nuage quand ils le souhaitent mais alors
allez sur le domaine des EPI qui doivent
être documentées
ça ça crée des obligations pour des
éditeurs de logiciels qui ne sont pas
raisonnables
ce n'est plus l'économie d'aujourd'hui
l'économie des épis
d'aujourd'hui c'est celle de la donnée
et les épi représentent finalement une
publication de propriétés intellectuelle
peu auproux quoi qu'on dise donc et donc
il faut s'en méfier il y a beaucoup de
pression en Europe parce qu'il y a un
certain nombre de pays qui sont très
favorables à cette récupération de
propriété intellectuelle et il faut donc
il faut donc se méfier de ce concept de
la même manière qu'il faut se méfier du
concept
d'équivalence fonctionnelle
puisque là c'est pareil ça ne veut pas
dire grand chose l'équivalent
fonctionnel quand on attaque des couches
de logiciel qui ne sont pas simplement
une infrastructure de mémorisation et de
calcul mais mais de la plateforme ou
bien du logiciel dans l'informatique en
nuage
donc voilà ce que je dirais sur les
actifs numériques cette définition est
dangereuse et vraiment je vous encourage
à regarder ce sujet et à revenir au
concept qui est aujourd'hui j'espère
celui qui sera inscrit dans le Data acte
européen qui est le concept de donner
exportable
j'imagine que vous avez des propositions
à nous faire sur le sujet
bien entendu on a des propositions à
faire d'amendement très précis qu'on
peut vous fournir
et je dirais que sur le sujet de la
recette
finalement quand on veut permettre cette
portabilité de nez des données il faut
avoir des standards finalement c'est ça
que ça veut dire il faut que ces données
elles répondent à certains standards et
c'est comme ça qu'on peut les rendre
réutilisables d'un service à l'autre ces
standards ne sont pas des standards
français là je crois qu'il faut être
relativement clair je
désolé d'être un peu brutal mais
l'élaboration standard est quelque chose
de long et onéreux
et je pense qu'on aurait intérêt à miser
sur l'élaboration de standards européens
en la matière parce que c'est une tâche
compliquée il faut que les industriels
qui sont les consommateurs des données
soit impliqués il faut éviter de faire
des standards je dirais intellectuels
les standards moi que je connais parce
qu'on a participé nous d'assot système à
des organismes de standardisation bien
entendu comme step par exemple et bien
ces organismes de standardisation ils
travaillent
en réunissant les industriels concernés
et donc on a un standard step pour
l'automobile il existe un standard step
pour l'aéronautique et les industriels
concernés participent à l'élaboration
des standards parce que ce sont leurs
données ils sont concernés et ils y
participent avec des éditeurs de
logiciels du type d'assosystème donc
voilà ce que je dirais larsep on a le
haute opinion pour la recette mais je
pense que la mission d'élaborer tous les
standards nécessaires à la portabilité
des données et tout à fait
au dessus des moyens de la recette
alors qui souhaitent s'exprimer sur les
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur Smet
donc pour des raisons très différentes
nous avons chez euclidia des conclusions
similaires sur les sujets actifs
numériques fonctionnels norme ce genre
de choses alors très différente pour
nous c'est très bien que les API soient
public pour nous il y a pas de propriété
intellectuelle sur les API c'est plutôt
ce genre là mais notre conclusion est
cependant la même à partir d'un point de
vue très différent et par exemple sur le
fait de confier à l'arcom quelque chose
qui ressemble à d'un standardisation du
cloud alors pour moi personnellement
c'est proche d'une abomination parce que
l'arcom c'est l'ARCEP c'est les gens des
télécoms les gens des télécoms c'est le
déterminisme c'est pas tout à fait
pareil
elles sont deux autorités indépendantes
différentes qui n'ont pas le café les
mêmes missions si je peux me permettre
je parlais de la recette donc là pardon
lacep c'est les gens qui ont préféré le
Minitel et x-25 à TCPIP et au web
et ça reste dans leur façon de penser la
standardisation la même chose
aujourd'hui avec le 3GPP
il n'y je ne connais pas de personne à
la recette qui comprennent ce que c'est
que le logiciel je connais des gens qui
comprennent des télés comme très bien
parfait mais en logiciel je n'en connais
pas par ailleurs l'idée de normalisation
des systèmes dans le monde du logiciel
je vous mets au défi de me donner
d'autres normes adoptées réellement
autre que tronc alors je pense vous la
connaissez pas c'est au Japon
les la norme du W3C comme façon de
représenter un exécutable portable et
POSIX et en dehors de ces trois normes
qui permettent de garantir que quelque
chose va tourner à un endroit et un
autre et bien défini j'en connais pas
d'autres
et donc dites moi une autre et donc
voyez on est dans un débat extrêmement
technique alors nous nous légiférons
voilà et ce que c'est pour ça que je me
permets un petit peu de recentrer aussi
le débat par rapport aux questions de
nos rapports nous ce qui nous importe et
que le texte de loi permet l'émergence
d'un cloud souverain français et
européen qui aujourd'hui est un peu en
retrait parce que c'était hégémonique et
les cafards les prédateurs on les
connaît et qui sont en train de
vampiriser tout ce marché en plein
développement Orient dans le jeu de
souveraineté nous donner elles sont
extrêmement sensibles stratégiques donc
nous voici savoir si le texte de loi
voilà ça vous satisfait parce que ça
permet de sortir des griffes des
gafables qui se sont tout appropriées
alors cette réversibilité portabilité
donnée et de migrer vers des solutions
que vous offrez qui respectent les
valeurs européennes ça qui nous importe
de savoir ce que le texte vous satisfait
ce qu'on doit aller plus loin est-ce
qu'on doit par exemple inscrire dans le
texte cette notion de données
stratégique et sensible vous voyez il y
a y a des questions quelles politiques
industrielle pour accompagner aussi
votre secteur
c'est des questions nous plus
stratégiques en fait que nous nous
posons chers collègues me tourne vers
vous que des questions pardonnez nous on
est un peu ignare
en technologie en tout cas pour ma part
voilà ce que disait monsieur terres sens
sur le sujet de la normalisation c'est
ce qui est écrit dans le texte
et jusqu'à dit Monsieur Tersan qui est
exact c'est que la notion de données
exportable de format de données
exportable c'est quelque chose où on
peut avoir de la normalisation mais
c'est pas ce qui est écrit dans le texte
et ce qui est écrit dans le texte fait
référence à quelque chose qui n'existe
pas
si vous me permettez pour rebondir sur
sur vos questions monsieur le rapporteur
et madame la Présidente alors sur votre
point madame le Président de concernant
le voilà si le texte nous satisfait pour
aller vers davantage de souveraineté
numérique là où le texte est à notre
sens très important et bienvenue et
marque aussi on peut lire une certaine
une certaine inflexion c'est que en
voilà en cherchant à réguler certaines
pratiques
covh à très bien décrite comme pouvant
être entre guillemets mortifère on va
participer en fait de cette forme de
rééquilibrage des conditions de
concurrence qui vont nous qui vont
permettre à ce qu'elle louer comme je
pense au reste de l'écosystème français
européen finalement de pouvoir montrer
leur valeur de façon plus plus juste et
équitable c'est peut-être le premier
point donc enfin sur l'intérêt du texte
entre guillemets soyez soyez fortement
rassuré ensuite sur les différentes vos
différentes questions alors pour
rebondir sur les propos de mon voisin la
même on a un peu les mêmes les mêmes
interrogations voir les mêmes craintes
sur cette définition de des actifs
numériques et alors vous vous demandiez
des propositions concrètes on peut vous
inviter à enfin voilà en faisant
référence à cette notion de donner
exportable etc mais à regarder la
définition qui est actuellement incluse
dans le la version des trilogues c'est
cette technique les plus légitime donc
vous saurez là vous y référer qui est
effectivement plus cadré plus précise et
plus concrète donc ça c'est peut-être un
premier point de d'orientation
sur
sur la notion de portabilité alors à
notre connaissance mais c'est peut-être
encore une fois approfondir mais c'était
cette notion de portabilité n'est pas
définie dans le détail donc il y a
peut-être un sujet
et portabilité dans le contexte du Cloud
et donc n'est pas encore voté bien sûr
bien sûr donc on est en anticipation de
ce qui pourrait être bien sûr mais donc
il y aura à l'échelle européenne dans
cette phase ultérieure de normalisation
standardisation un sujet de savoir à
quelle définition on se réfère et donc
le fait d'anticiper probablement au
niveau français cette phase là peut
permettre alors c'est aussi de déjà
commencer à
anticiper ces travaux à réfléchir à des
définitions qui pourront après être
proactivement et plus rapidement porté
au niveau européen donc ça ça peut être
aussi un élément intéressant de de
mandater ou de Taski entre guillemets
leur CEP pour pour orienter ses travaux
et anticiper la phase de mise en oeuvre
là pour le coup du datac qui arrivera un
peu plus tard sur les frais de transfert
alors
finalement je pense que on a relatif
consensus entre
sur ce sujet dans le sens où la même
façon on ne facture pas de frais de
digresse comme on dit en anglais de
frais de transfert hormis de façon
peut-être très très marginale mais très
très impactant
quand on sait que un certain nombre
d'acteurs dominants peuvent avoir des
marges sur ces frais de transfert de
l'ordre de 800% par rapport à ce qu'on
estimait des cours réels alors c'est à
vérifier c'est approfondir mais c'est
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée ceci
étant dit donc l'encadrement ou
l'interdiction de ces frais transferts
pour nous est une excellente chose parce
que ça permet de livrer un vrai un vrai
verrouillage ceci étant dit le diable
étant dans les détails on a un petit peu
comme comme vous cette cette
interrogation sur le fait de mieux
peut-être définir ses frais de transfert
très concrètement contre des frais de
migration comment on différencie l'un de
l'autre pourquoi on interdit l'un et pas
l'autre par des conséquence
pour tout simplement éviter des voix
potentielles de contournement donc ça
c'est un élément qui est qui est
important et point par ailleurs aussi
important et qui est une différence je
pense entre la disposition du Data
peut-être et le texte le projet de loi
qu'on regarde actuellement
le fait de potentiellement interdire
entre guillemets tout de suite ces frais
de transfert pour nous ne poserait aucun
problème parce que non justifié par des
impératifs techniques donc versus une
période de transition potentiellement au
niveau européen voilà le fait de lever
tout de suite ce frein permettra
vraiment de renforcer tout de suite
aussi la liberté de choix des
utilisateurs derrière et peut-être
dernier point et je sais pas si j'aurai
pris toutes vos questions
si ce n'est pas le cash mon excuse sur
les
les offres de crédit cloud alors
ou de points là-dessus
d'abord alors quand vous faisiez
référence madame la Présidente au fait
que c'était des offres offertes par des
hyperscalaires Américains par des
acteurs extra-hops je pense qu'il faut
être tout à fait honnête et transparent
vis-à-vis de vous ce qu'elle est par
exemple pour éviter votre question
monsieur le monsieur le rapporteur ce
qu'elle est loué par exemple propose des
offres de crédit cloud à l'attention
d'un écosystème de développeurs de
start-up évidemment pas du tout dans les
mêmes proportions dans les mêmes
montants et à la même échelle que les
acteurs dominants
mais du fait d'une certaine forme de de
la culturation à des prix négatifs on
est obligé quelque part aujourd'hui de
proposer ses offres
le premier point par contre
effectivement dans la mesure où on ne
peut pas avoir la même ampleur de de
distribution de feux gratuites ça crée
une véritablement un biais là où je veux
en venir malgré tout donc
réfléchir à cet encadrement étudié cette
pratique et quelque chose est quelque
chose de d'intéressant probablement à
regarder là où je veux quand même
apporter une petite nuance c'est que
donc cet encadrement des crédits cloud
ne figure pas comme vous le savez dans
le Data Act c'est une disposition qui
est propre à ce projet de loi
et donc on va aboutir à une situation
potentiellement ou cet encadrement sera
spécifique ou territoire national
on sait déjà aujourd'hui qui peut y
avoir des voies de contournement assez
facile à ce dispositif dans le sens où
si des filiales extra française non
française des acteurs dominants
contribuent à distribuer ces crédits à
des entités françaises le PGL et c'est
heureux ne vise pas à interdire
l'utilisation mais encadrer l'octroi et
donc on pourrait aboutir à une situation
qui serait probablement un peu
paradoxale ou inverse à l'effet
rechercher qui serait finalement
d'encadrer uniquement cette octroi de
crédit Cloud pour des acteurs français
situés sur le territoire national et qui
n'aurait pas les moyens de contourner
entre guillemets cette encadrement et ça
du coup il faut je pense être assez
attentif aux effets de bord que ça
pourrait créer
pour ne pas que ça détourne des clients
potentiels effectivement de de nos
offres après sur le fait de d'étudier
les les offres relatives de crédit Cloud
et de gratuité de différents acteurs ça
je pense que c'est c'est un élément qui
est effectivement tout à fait important
sur vous pour nous aider à bien définir
ces frais de transfert et à pouvoir
trouver le bon équilibre dans la
rédaction donc c'est évident donc
j'entends à ce que vous dites et je le
partage mais donc aujourd'hui il faut
trouver la
bonne définition pour pouvoir donc faire
en sorte d'atteindre l'objectif sur les
crédits cloud j'entends aussi ce que
vous dites et il y a effectivement un
effet pervers c'est le risque de priver
certaines startups de d'un
accompagnement
utile à leur développement donc là aussi
il faut effectivement trouver le bon
équilibre mais je
pour l'instant je pense pas qu'il faille
s'interdire d'être peut-être plus
vertueux et donc
trouver le bon équilibre qui permette à
la fois d'éviter donc
que les entreprises américaines
préemptent donc le marché et donc
accompagné malgré tout les startup
française
tout à fait en ligne avec votre analyse
pour pour cloud peut-être oui donc pour
répondre aux questions qui ont été
posées
tout d'abord sur le crédit cloud je
partage beaucoup des choses qui ont été
qui ont été dites
aujourd'hui la difficulté qu'on a sur
les critères critique cloud c'est que
d'un côté ces vertueux pour
l'écosystème des startups et des
scalopes françaises et européennes qui
ont pour des raisons diverses envies
besoin de migrer sur le Cloud qui
hésitent à passer le pas et il faut les
accompagner donc c'est quelque chose qui
qui répond à un besoin de notre
écosystème de start-up et il ne faut il
ne faut pas
il ne faut pas oublier ce besoin là
d'un autre côté on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que les clés de Cloud sont
détournées leur finalité de outils
d'accompagnement pour tester le Cloud
pour découvrir si ça correspond aux
besoins quels sont les enjeux cela
devient un produit d'appel pour attirer
ces start-up instable très précoces de
leur développement et les verrouiller
donc aujourd'hui
complètement exclure les crédits cloud
serait peut-être extrême et pour être
transparent nous aussi chez OVH cloud
nous avons une politique de de crédit de
crédit
d'informatique en nuage de ce qu'on
appelle le crédit cloud mais qui est
assez modérée ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui donc dit cloud c'est un le
détournement et de le fait que des
acteurs et ont des des
poches profondes puissent proposer des
crédits cloud un montant qui est
impossible à répliquer pour de plus
petits acteurs c'est ce décalage là qui
pose aujourd'hui un énorme problème
c'est pas le crédith Cloud en soi donc
la
l'approche que nous que nous défendons
plutôt je Cloud et de dire que
il faut un encadrement précis des
crédits cloud avec des montants
limités qui peuvent être facilement
réplicables par des acteurs plus
modestes limité dans le temps et surtout
surtout cela doit rester un test c'est à
dire que une start-up une société
quelconque qui bénéficie de crédit Cloud
pour décrire le Cloud doit pouvoir
sortir à tout moment sans être
verrouillé c'est un test aujourd'hui
quand je m'abonne au journal Le Monde
qui me propose un mois offert pour
tester et ensuite je peux sortir je peux
sortir je ne paye rien avant le premier
mois le crédit cloud devrait avoir la
même approche afin de ne pas verrouiller
le client donc ça c'est le premier point
et après en termes de mon temps
on peut en discuter notre approche si on
se dit que maximum entre 6 mois et un an
en terme de durée entre 6 mois et un an
de gratuité ça serait bien avec un cap
peut-être avoir ce sont des acteurs mais
un cap maximum à 50.000 euros sur
l'année pourraient être peut-être
envisageable dans un certain nombre de
cas mais c'est difficile pour être tout
à fait honnête c'est difficile de donner
un montant précis pour tous les acteurs
donc c'est quelque chose qui est qui qui
est difficile à mesurer quoi qu'il en
soit la logique de secret cloud c'est
que c'est un dispositif sain qui a été
dévoyé et il faut aujourd'hui rendre sa
fonction première au dispositif c'est un
dispositif de test qui ne doit pas
rendre le client captif
donc ça c'est et qui doit pouvoir
duplicable par tout l'industrie
si je vous entends bien c'est que vous
êtes favorable à une limitation à la
fois dans le temps et en montant
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelque chose de
cumulé parce qu'aujourd'hui on a plutôt
enfin plutôt pris de la part notamment
du ministre que ce qui était sa voix
c'était la limitation dans le temps
exclusivement je pense que si on
n'a pas une imitation également en
montant on va avoir une vraie différence
une vraie distorsion de concurrence
entre les acteurs mais après voilà après
les montants sont c'est si difficile
d'exprimer j'ai donné des éléments de
valeur mais c'est très difficile donc
c'est pas mon rôle de le faire mais bon
ensuite sur les frais de transfert
donc tout d'abord OVH cloud n'applique
pas de frais de sortie de contrat je
pense que le texte de loi aujourd'hui
doit identifier je reprends ce qui a été
dit auparavant par par mes par notamment
par hotskal et parce qu'elle est
il convient de définir de quoi on parle
on parle de frais de transfert de frais
de migration je pense qu'il faut
distinguer la notion frais de transfert
qui est la circulation de la donnée
pendant le contrat c'est à dire que
quand un client est client d'un
fournisseur de Cloud au quotidien ça
donnait elle peut sortir des serveurs
parce que le client fait ce qu'on
appelle du multicloud donc c'est-à-dire
qu'il a plusieurs opérateurs de Cloud en
même temps et en fonction des services
la localisation et de plein de raisons
très légitimes le client intérêt à avoir
plusieurs fournisseurs entre lesquels ça
donnait va circuler
il peut y avoir des problématiques aussi
de backup et puis énormément de
problématiques qui font que pendant la
durée du contrat la circulation de la
donnée doit être
complètement alors je sais jamais si on
dit transparente ça peut interpréter de
façon différente mais le doit pas être
source de de facturation du client
[Musique]
orientés coût uniquement et coût
spécifiquement engagés pour la migration
donc on a parlé de prestations de
services humaines de il y a
effectivement des ressources qui peuvent
parfois être mises en place
d'accompagnement de techniciens pour
accompagner le client sa migration mais
tout ce qui est frais de bande passante
ou de choses comme ça
c'est la pas de sens c'est la bonne sens
quand un fournisseur de Cloud voit
rentrer un client qui lui apporte des
données mais quand il parle les données
partent il ne va pas lui faire ce péage
vous allez utiliser le mot de péage tout
à l'heure monsieur le rapporteur on ne
va pas le faire passer sur ce péage donc
la difficulté du texte c'est d'avoir
précision dans la définition entre frais
transfert frais de migration et
qu'est-ce qui est exclu la prestation
humaine d'accompagnement à la migration
est une prestation qui mérite salaire
orientée plutôt coup par contre tout le
reste il y a en tout cas côté vache
cloud nous n'appliquons pas de frais sur
le reste et nous nous facturons pas nos
clients sur le reste et nous ne
comprenons pas ce qui pourrait être
facturé donc nous invitons effectivement
à la suppression de ces frais qui sont
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
sens pas justifié
ensuite sur les questions plus
techniques
d'interopérabilité d'actifs numériques
[Musique]
alors le texte va dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire que ce sont des problèmes
aujourd'hui et on va pas se voiler la
face nous avons ce problème là
l'interopérabilité est un problème est
une barrière à la migration entre
fournisseurs de Cloud et
l'absence de de portabilité des données
l'est aussi
en revanche ce sont effectivement des
définitions sensibles qui peuvent avoir
des effets de bord donc Thibault de
terre sans doute qu'elle on a parlé
aujourd'hui l'interopérabilité c'est
quoi
l'interopérabilité c'est la faculté pour
des systèmes des applications des
composants différents de pouvoir se
connecter partager fonctionner ensemble
parler entre eux
et cette opérabilité n'est pas naturelle
et parfois il faut la forcer
ce qui est très important à faire et
pourquoi nous pensons que le texte doit
quand même aller vers de
interopérabilité c'est que si on ne
règle pas à ce problème en excenté en
ayant des fixant les conditions pour
avoir une bonne interopérabilité
qu'est-ce qui va se passer je vais vous
le dire on va voir des acteurs dominants
qui ont toujours pu dominant on a quand
même trois acteurs qui font 71% du
marché en France 70% 72 % en Europe qui
vont avoir leur propre formats qui vont
imposer leur propre format et ça on le
voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quand alors j'ai pas donné de nom mais
quand certains hyperscaler américain
fait des modifications sur ces c'est sur
ces formats sur ces services
tout le reste de l'industrie cavale pour
se mettre à niveau et dans ce sens-là ce
n'est pas possible parce que ça veut
dire que le dominant va imposer son
modèle va imposer un standard de fait à
tout le marché
et c'est ça qui doit être anticipé
appréhendée par le texte de loi et c'est
pour ça que le la loi doit aller vers
l'interopérabilité et doit aller vers
des notions de portabilité après
j'entends ce qui a été dit sur le fait
que des définitions peuvent avoir des
effets de bord qu'il faut effectivement
les travailler pour éviter ces effets de
bord on a parlé de la notion d'actifs
numériques oui c'est la donnée
exportable mais pas que je donnais un
exemple très peut-être un peu imagé et
excusez moi mais quand vous déménagez
sur déménageurs et vous revenez toutes
les affaires en vrac de votre salon vous
avez pas réussi à en faire grand chose
et vous allez vous mettre beaucoup de
temps à tout retrouver donc il faut que
la donnée la portabilité le principe de
la portabilité c'est qu'il faut que la
donnée soit transmise dans un format
structuré
couramment utilisé lisible donc oui
c'est la donnée mais la donnée
structurée lisible pour que le client
puisse la réutiliser et donc si dans
cette direction là qu'à notre sens
devrait aller le projet de loi
merci alors je me tends vers mes
collègues est-ce que l'un ou l'autre
d'entre vous a une question en
particulier c'est un sujet qui a
complexe pas facile à aborder
moi j'ai une deux trois alors je vous ai
coupé la parole
de Me sur le rapporteur qui n'a pas été
traité je crois qu'il a commencé son
intervention en disant il y a du retard
est-ce que c'est rattrapable
bonne question et j'allais dire nuspot
n'existerait pas si on pensait que ça
n'était pas rattrapable mais je vais
peut-être dire je vais peut-être dire
effectivement pourquoi
le projet de loi qui est proposé va
effectivement dans le bon sens pour
permettre à des acteurs de rattraper ce
retard et je partage ce qui a ce qui a
pu être dit il y a j'allais dire
d'autres éléments qui sont de nature à
favoriser
l'émergence d'acteurs et le fait de
rattraper ce retard je crois madame la
Présidente que vous avez soulignée qui
avait une mise à jour de la doctrine
cloud au centre qui a été faite
récemment elle va dans le bon sens parce
que elle rappelle qu'il y a toujours
cette doctrine qui n'est pas remise en
cause et elle en a précisé le contour
exact des données à sensibilité
particulière qui sont de nature à
justifier du cloud check-nuclable donc
ça va dans le bon sens tout cela est
rattrapé et j'allais dire et confirmer
et
préciser et au moins pour le secteur
public parce que ça s'adresse au secteur
public les choses sont claires je dirais
juste il suffira que le secteur public
veuille bien passer des commandes et
commander et aller dans le Cloud pour
pouvoir aussi faire émerger et émerger
ses acteurs là mais pour le coup les
choses les choses sont claires la loi va
permettre d'y aider et je dirais il y a
un troisième levier qui est aussi
intéressant à pouvoir faire jouer pour
influencer les acteurs ou influencer le
marché c'est l'utilisateur final et donc
je pense qu'il y a un bel effort à faire
sur la sensibilisation de l'acteur final
qui infinie et celui qui guidera le
marché et
il y a le cyberscore qui existe et qui
est dans le paysage à l'image d'une
nutri-score je pense que vous voyez très
bien ce qu'il en est
je dirais que ce qui sort du cyberscore
pour l'instant je sais pas si c'est ça
qui pour qu'il faudrait être retenu pour
l'instant c'est assez timide
c'est-à-dire qu'en 2024 ça touche très
très gros acteurs en 2020-2025 ça
touchera quelques acteurs mais
aujourd'hui si vous voulez aller sur un
site qui est dans le Cloud j'allais dire
bon courage pour savoir où sont vos
données pour savoir quelle en est
l'hébergeur pour savoir si vos données
sont soumises à un quelconque ou pas
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour autant
je pense que l'éducation des
utilisateurs plus la sensibilité que
peuvent avoir un certain nombre est
importante et de nature à influencer le
fournisseur de services quant à savoir
ce qu'il faut faire de ces données ou
autre ou pas et donc une accélération
sur cet équivalence cyberscore ou
nutri-score appliqué sur la sécurité des
données en visibilité utilisateur serait
de mon point de vue de toute évidence un
autre levier qui permettrait de faire
émerger des acteurs plus vertueux
vis-à-vis de la sécurité la
confidentialité des données et de ce que
l'on peut en faire
merci vous avez rappelé la labellisation
c'est que nous cloud donc qui a été mise
en place donc par le gouvernement
certains acteurs des plus petites
entreprises sans doute que celle que
vous représentez m'ont fait valoir que
le processus de labellisation vous
l'avez dit vous-même et très long 18
mois et coûtent cher on m'a parlé par
exemple de 50
000 euros pour une petite entreprise
c'est beaucoup est-ce que vous confirmez
est-ce que oui monsieur alors dans le
clivia nous avons deux types de membres
il y a ceux qui ont subi un chantage à
Seclin cloud de
quand ils ont eu des subventions ont une
demande
de l'État d'accepter de devenir secte
d'une cloud ou de ne pas avoir de
subventions ça a permis ensuite faire
une annonce donc cela maintenant ont du
mal à critiquer secmincloud ils sont
très minoritaires
et on a la Vasse majorité pour qui
secume cloud favorise les technologies
américaines de Cloud puisque si on
regarde aujourd'hui les offres des
hébergements secs d'une cloud il y en a
quatre pour ces quatre offres le cœur
technology je parle pas du système de
vente autour qui a été développé je
parle du cœur cœur technologique c'est
de l'américain propriétaire qui ne
permet pas de garantir l'immunité à une
prise de contrôle à distance par un État
tiers comme l'explique Edward Snowden
par exemple sur les équipements Cisco ou
comme on peut le lire quand on voit ce
qui existe dans les logiciels
propriétaires d'origine américaine donc
sec num Cloud
favorise en réalité l'absence d'offres à
base de technologie européenne et
l'autre partie c'est qu'il favorise
également les offres propriétaires
contre les logiciels libres qui
pourraient être en fait une violation de
la loi sur je crois la République des
murs numériques d'Axel Lemaire puisque
quand vous prenez un logiciel libre
Lancy vous demande de vérifier
l'inaligne chaque contribution vous
pouvez pas déléguer facilement à
quelqu'un d'autre la confiance sur
l'insertion de code libre et donc on
voit un certain nombre de personnes
aujourd'hui qui essaient de faire du
sexe in cloud qui sont extrêmement
défavorisés quand ils prennent du
logiciel libre puis on pourrait même
dire que non seulement ce que demande la
dernière circulaire c'est du Seclin
cloud mais en plus immune à un accès à
distance par un État tiers donc dès que
vous prenez un processeur Intel ou AMD
le processeur contient un dispositif
d'accès à distance
contrôlable par les États-Unis donc en
fait on peut se dire aujourd'hui il
n'existe aucune offre conforme à la
demande de la circulaire club de centre
mise à jour
sous cette donc c'est c'est
on va dire la majorité des membres ce
qui est demandé est absurde et
défavorise l'industrie européenne
monsieur de terre sans vous
très franchement on a besoin d'une norme
exigeante si on veut garantir la
sécurité des données et un contrôle de
souveraineté de ces données c'est ce que
fait c'est que new Cloud et aujourd'hui
il y a effectivement beaucoup de
pression pour arriver à
minorer cette norme et abaisser
finalement son niveau d'exigence
abaisser son niveau d'exigence
dépression alors vous savez il y a c'est
John launcher qui ont été qui sont en
cours de création qui ont déjà été créés
avec des hyperscalers Américains il y a
il y a des noms bizarres sens bleu
c'est bleu c'est Microsoft
un certain nombre de projets en réalité
et qui sont assez intéressés à ce qui
est un abaissement de la norme c'est que
cette norme enfin je sais pas nous on
est passé au travers et on a on a obtenu
et elle est extrêmement exigeante mais
c'est une bonne chose je crois que les
délais sont en train d'être réduits tout
en gardant l'exigence moi j'attire
l'attention sur le fait qu'on a besoin
de garder une norme exigeante si on veut
garantir la sécurité des données il y a
un autre point sur lequel j'aurais voulu
réagir en un mot c'est le point sur
fixer un montant maximum de crédit de
Cloud
je pense que on peut encadrer la durée
de ces crédits de
d'informatique en nuages mais fixer un
montant maximum
va nuire à notre capacité à en fait
faire migrer
des grands clients existants qui
aujourd'hui travaillent avec des
fournisseurs américains ou chinois vers
des environnements français donc parce
que on sera plafonné tout le monde pense
évidemment au start-up quand on fixe un
montant mais il n'y a pas que les
startups il y a aussi tout un tas
d'autres sociétés et comme je rebondis
sur ce que disait Alain issarny on a
bien l'intention quand même de les
gagner
et de ne pas simplement considérer qu'on
a perdu la bataille
donc je voulais revenir là-dessus et il
y a un dernier point que je voudrais
signaler parce qu'il se trouve dans le
Data Act c'est finalement
l'insécurité contractuelle c'est à dire
le fait que dans le Data acte il y a une
disposition qui dit que tout client peut
interrompre son contrat avec un délai de
préavis de 60 jours
alors vu de loin ça paraît bien puisque
ça permet de redonner la liberté en
réalité
ceci n'est pas aujourd'hui dans le
projet sren mais j'en parle parce qu'il
faudrait pas que ça se retrouve dans le
projet sren car si on veut développer
des Cloud
on part quand même pas de situation
où on a des cloud considérables en
France ils sont petits donc là bon
si on veut gagner des Grands Comptes on
ne peut pas le faire sans un engagement
pluriannuel pourquoi parce que gagner un
grand compte veut dire qu'il faut faire
des investissements très importants en
matériel en serveur et en salle blanche
et on ne peut pas faire ces
investissements si on n'a pas une
sécurité contractuelle
généralement en fait de trois ans contre
laquelle on donne d'ailleurs des rabais
puisque quand on demande un engagement
plus réel à un client on lui donne en
échange un rabais important et donc
si on perd cette sécurité de
l'engagement contractuel on ne va pas
pouvoir développer des cloud européens
aux Français c'est aussi simple que ça
et donc cette disposition dans le Data
acte elle est très pernicieuse
elle favorise en réalité nos grands
concurrents américains c'est ça la
vérité
et c'est comme ça que effectivement
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
qui arrivent qui vont également dans le
même genre de direction on a un texte
sur le cyber résilience Act qui conduit
aujourd'hui les gens qui font un
logiciel libre à risquer de devoir payer
15 millions d'euros d'amende pour les
erreurs qu'aurait faites un utilisateur
de leur logiciel qui ne leur a rien payé
pour l'utiliser donc ça ça donne à envie
d'arrêter de faire des logiciels libres
pour obtenir la norme je crois que c'est
25000 euros plus du caera plus
50% de plus en coût de développement on
trouve le même genre de disposition dans
la directive
pilder clybellity directive je ne sais
je connais pas le nom français pareil on
met une responsabilité supplémentaire
sur des gens qui développent du logiciel
libre notamment pour le Cloud et qui le
partage dans la directive sur
l'intelligence artificielle on commence
par demander aux gens de s'inscrire dans
une base de données un métier qu'ils
vont respecter la démocratie qu'ils ont
mis en place un système de traçabilité
de leur code qui vérifient pour chacune
des lignes de leur code qu'elle est
conforme à toutes les lois européennes
avant de la partager avec les autres
développeurs de logiciel libre donc on a
une sorte d'accumulation de texte qui
renforce la charge qui est mise sur les
personnes qui développent les
technologies et ça va encore plus loin
puisque dans certains textes
il y a à peu près la même chose dans le
système des noms de domaine quand
quelqu'un se plaint il lance une
procédure
vous allez devoir payer pour faire cette
procédure et même si vous gagnez vous
serez pas remboursé donc il y aura pas
ce qui existe d'habitude dans la justice
donc on a
tout ce genre de texte donne
furieusement envie d'aller s'établir
ailleurs
quand on est producteur de technologie
donc OVH cloud à la certification avec
une Cloud et je tiens à préciser que
effectivement c'est un process long
forcément après le gouvernement a mis en
place un accompagnement pour qu'on
puisse obtenir un certificat donc on
n'est pas lâché dans la jungle de la
certification et cet accompagnement qui
est important OVH cloud elle-même va
accompagner est engagée auprès des
éditeurs de logiciels sur sur le sujet
pour les aider à comprendre le
l'écosystème donc il y a quand même
oui c'est long c'est un certain
investissement mais pour derrière me
semble-t-il un avantage concurrentiel
clé aujourd'hui dans cette classe on a
justement ajouté des critères d'immunité
ou loi extraterritoriales pour éviter un
certain nombre d'excellents stands de
risque et ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel quoique fasse nos hyperskylor
américain en tant qu'acteur européen on
pourra avec une certification de ce
niveau là on pourra avoir un avantage
concurrentiel qu'il est important de
préserver
vous êtes plusieurs à participer au
projet de plateforme qui peut-être une
alternative à Microsoft d'après ce que
nous aurions pu comprendre pour la
plateforme des données de santé sportive
si je m'abuse
est-ce que vous pourriez nous en dire
plus parce que voilà on connaît pas
l'état d'avancement du projet de l'offre
alternative à bleu en fait c'est ça donc
vous savez qu'ici on est très préoccupé
on a interpellé à plusieurs reprises les
différents ministres de la santé et du
numérique ainsi que la première ministre
qui nous a promis qu'il y aurait d'abord
un appel d'offres à l'époque en 2020
donc ça émue je crois Monsieur Bernard
Charlène de la société qui avait
interpellé le président de la République
en disant que de la société n'avait pas
été approchée dans le cas d'un appel
d'offre en bonne et due forme donc où on
est ce projet est-ce que il est
suffisamment et stratégiquement soutenu
et accompagné par la dilum par la DGE
c'est important je pense
répondre pour les principaux intéressés
donc
Pedro Luca qui en fait dirige une des
grandes entreprises françaises de
l'hébergement de santé et une de mes
entreprises avant
fait une offre il y a un ou deux ans au
Hells datab
d'un système complet de Data hub hébergé
avec toute la conformité alors avec
toutes les normes HDS
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
n-statum c'est depuis le début qui
existe des offres conformes et
européenne
Achille l'irpinière qui était travaillé
au elfs data hub connaît les produits
européens qui étaient déjà disponibles
au jour 1 pour faire un sdata hub 100%
européen
mais ce que nous dit le texte récent sur
le Cloud de confiance la circulaire de
du Premier ministre une dérogation pour
être accordée sans qu'elle ne puisse
aller au-delà de 12 mois après la date à
laquelle une offre de cloud acceptable
sera disponible en France donc on a un
mot qui s'appelle acceptable
qui permet de dire ce qu'on veut parce
que c'est pas le fait qu'il y a une
offre qui fonctionne ça existe depuis 4
ans au moins c'est qu'elle soit
acceptable mais selon quels critères
est-ce que c'est acceptable parce que ça
reprend toutes les Api de microsoft
dans ce cas on peut attendre longtemps
et donc la difficulté qu'on a ici c'est
ce mot acceptable ce mot acceptable
permet de continuer à avoir le
réalisateur chez Microsoft ad vitam
eternam puis la même chose au niveau
européen malgré l'existence d'une
pléthore d'offres 100% européenne
vous contredisez l'idée selon laquelle
nous n'aurions pas de
solutions
et d'alternative c'est un peu l'idée qui
avait été émise par sa secrétaire d'État
numérique et on voit un autodidment
permanent dans la sphère académique
politique et aux fonctionnaires très
clairement par rapport à nos propres
compétences est-ce que vous vous êtes
plusieurs représentants de ce secteur
est-ce que vous contredisez cette idée
en disant que tout ne se fera peut-être
pas en un jour mais qu'il y a on peut
progressivement récupérer une forme
d'autonomie stratégique et de
souveraineté en établissement des choix
préférentiels par exemple on va
commencer par nous administrations et
nos données sensibles et de la santé par
exemple et on peut construire
progressivement cette
écosystème parce que
nous on est convaincus et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a on a fait ce
projet nimspot newspot à vocation à
traiter des données de santé des
Français ça fait partie de la feuille de
route et Alain issarny peut certainement
le confirmer et voilà et on a bien
l'intention de faire valoir nos
arguments bien entendu qui sont des bons
arguments
je confirme c'est-à-dire que quand je le
disais en introduction et sur la
présentation de newspot l'ambition que
l'on a c'est de bâtir un Cloud j'allais
dire souverain et de confiance avec des
services évolués et managés qui nous
rapproche en fait de ce qui se pratique
par ailleurs donc on est clairement
positionné là-dessus pour essayer de les
mettre en oeuvre et et bien évidemment
nous serons ravis de pouvoir participer
à une compétition sur un appel d'offres
pour le HDH
bien nous sommes preneurs des
propositions que vous n'auriez pas pu
nous faire oralement parce que le temps
imparti était assez court sur un sujet
assez technique pour lequel on vous a
posé les questions intermédiaires
pardonne-nous mais nous sommes pas des
gros spécialistes comme vous bien
entendu
c'est important parce que bien sûr il y
a le cadre il y a la loi mais après il y
a toute la stratégie industrielle qui va
accompagner très concrètement et
financièrement ces projets de Cloud
souverain donc certainement dans ce
cadre-là à l'instar de ce que vous avez
aussi évoqué monsieur Smet il y a des
propositions à nous et des idées et des
recommandations à nous à nous fournir
donc on attend beaucoup de vous voilà on
vous remercions de vous être rendus
disponible mais c'était tout à fait
important parce que c'est une partie de
l'article 7 à 14 c'est important dans le
texte
mes chers collègues nous prenons à 16h30